if you ever go to a music festival
especially a music festival in the uk
you might come across the problem that
there's always lots of toilets for you
to choose from and the problem with
these toilets that they're not always
that well looked after i have been to
quite a few music festivals and numerous
times have i come across this problem
[Music]
so the mathematical part of this problem
is let's say that you're in the queue
and you get to the first toilet and you
open the door and it's really not that
nice you really don't want to use that
toilet so it's okay you can try the next
toilet you open the door but it might be
marginally better but it's still not
that good the problem is you've got
hundreds of these toilets and how do you
know which toilet to stop on and decide
yep i'm going to use that toilet
so you don't have to try them all there
must be a set number and optimum number
we can look at so there are two things
that we do need to stick to on this
problem the first is that ideally i'm
looking for the best toilet the most
hygienic the cleanest toilet one with
plenty of toilet paper in there and hand
sanitizer and has been looked after
number two is that you can't go back to
a previous toilet there are people
queuing behind you if you reject a
toilet you can't go back to it so i'll
start with a small example where the
number of toilets actually quite small
to begin with it's a small music
festival just so we can see what's
happening so here are my three toilets
now i'm going to number them
one two and three
and the numbers relate to how hygienic
they are so number one that's the best
toilet the most hygienic number two not
quite as hygienic number three the worst
you certainly wouldn't want to choose
this one okay so the toilets at the
moment are lined up in this order but
it's not necessarily going to be always
this order i could have came to the
toilet and actually number one might
have been in the first position but
number three could have been second and
number two could have been third and if
we think about the number of
permutations of the order of these
toilets there are actually four more so
there are six permutations which is
three factorial so the likelihood that
the first toilet you go into is the
cleanest is quite slim especially as the
number of toilets gets larger so let's
say that we are always going to reject
the first toilet and then we'll choose
the next best out of our options
so if we take consideration of the first
example
we're going to reject toilet one even
though it is the best i don't know it's
the best because i can't compare it yet
i then take the best possible option
after that two when i compare it to one
is worse so i can't take two three
although it is also worse than one and
two i have no more toilets left to
choose so unfortunately i have to go
with the worst toilet in this case
that's a bad ending
if we take the second case again i
reject the first toilet three is worse
than one so i reject three and this time
i have to select two if we move on to
the third example i reject two
now one is better than two so because it
is better i choose that one straight
away and i stop if i just reject two on
the fourth example
three is worse than two so i move on to
the next toilet and because it's the
last toilet i select that toilet and
then for here i get three one is better
than three so i select one and i stop
here i get three
two is better than three so this time
i'd select two and i stop so if we take
a look at how many times i actually
chose the best toilet the most hygienic
there are one two
three
so there are three out of six chants or
a half which is
fifty percent chance
that would have chosen the correct most
hygienic toilet okay so this is fine for
when we only have three toilets but what
happens when we have four
with four toilets we'll now have 24
different permutations we have to
consider every single one now if you
work through it in the same way we'll
find that we actually only successful on
out of 24 of those opportunities
which is a percentage of about
46 percent this is successful at finding
the best possible the best possible
toilet so toilet number one
so the percentage is already decreased
by only including one extra toilet as n
gets larger i.e the number of toilets
gets larger this percentage gets smaller
and smaller and smaller so the idea of
rejecting the first toilet and taking
the next best one after that is quite
limited we can see that as n gets large
it doesn't give us an optimal solution
so of course at music festivals there
are hundreds of toilets so we'd like a
solution that gives us a better
approximation for this percentage to
give us a better likelihood of finding
the best toilet so we're going to do it
with a little bit of maths i'm going to
stop the video here because as you
probably guessed things are about to get
pretty mathematical
so i'm going to give you a choice
if you want to see all the mathematics
that leads to the answer here go to the
number file 2 channel and i've put all
of the rest of this video there and it's
it's a bit over 15 minutes long if you
haven't got time for that you want to
just get straight to the answer maybe
you're late for a music festival
yourself
stay here and we'll cut straight to the
chase but i do recommend the mathematics
it's really interesting i think most
people will follow it and there's more
really good animations from pete
so
make a choice
i'll give you a second
okay so here's the deal
once dr simmons has done all the
mathematics it comes down to this the
best thing to do
is to look inside 37
of the toilets and after you hit that 37
tipping point
you choose the first toilet after that
that's better than everything that came
before
that gives you the best chance of ending
up in the best toilet that doesn't mean
you can skip that first 37 you've
actually got to look inside them
unfortunately so that you can make the
comparison after you've gone past the
tipping point after you've gone past
that 37
to make it really simple imagine
glastonbury imagine a hundred toilets
you've got to look inside 37 and after
the 37th
pick the first one after that that's
better than what came before so we've
used the example of choosing the best
toilet but this is a famous mathematical
problem that you may have seen before in
a different context you may have heard
it before called the secretary problem
which is the same process this time
you want to find the best secretary for
the job but you are going to interview
a number of people so maybe 100 people
you can only accept or reject each
secretary once they be interviewed so
when do you stop
interviewing those secretaries and start
accepting one of them hoping that you
have the best for the job or another
famous use of this is in the dating
world if you want to find the best
partner your soulmate out there then how
many people should you date before you
should start accepting and settling down
with that next person and hoping that
that is the person you're supposed to be
with for the rest of your life
thanks for watching just a reminder you
can still go and look at all the
mathematics behind this over on number
file 2. we've got all the stuff worked
out by dr simmons and more excellent
animations from pete mcpartlin we don't
actually expect people to do this at
music festivals by the way it's just a
bit of a fun twist on an old problem
that everyone talks about all the time
we didn't want to make it about
secretaries and dating so
why not toilets